welcome to this video against Syrian
with black that's high rated player I am
xiran do I have a name let's check mail
is I'm a bad dear Wow okay let's stick
with Cecilia I've got a pretty good
score with it in the recent games okay
just playing the regular clothes
Sicilian that's not a bad line for white
it's totally out of fashion but it's not
not really bad I close Sicilian yeah
it's going for the the old the old line
here with with an f4 and so on nowadays
they pretty often play um other things
with no ID Bishop e3 and so on yeah
that's a funny line e takes d5 a plane
I'd f5 something that I studied Oh a
lifetime ago
yeah I'm clarifying the situation in the
center now oh really that looks strange
that look strange I mean I'm not so sure
if I get to keep this pawn but looks
still looks weird to to allow this kind
of thing okay so 94 here interesting
okay I tried to I tried to get a
situation where he's game that I can get
rid of my somewhat problematic bishop
yeah the a6 Bishop can easily become
somewhat superfluous p so i was eager to
get it traded h5 maybe not necessary but
if you want to play quickly you have to
make some of those decisions in in short
order okay try for d for huh so is going
for g for what exactly uh-huh I and I
i-90 46 okay okay i kim you're
interesting I'm trying to put the night
on 85 which should be quite okay
let's see does he want to move the Queen
and give away a true or not I mean it's
not clear that taking on a 2 is so great
but still after the green trade I'm
definitely okay okay in terms of being
equal I think hmm so what now they move
I did not think about at all I mean
really not at all okay okay I grab it
yeah is playing interesting stuff here
very interesting
not sure how good it really is but it's
very interesting e 6f 69 f 7 is this
great for white maybe it is but I don't
really know okay so i can move the rock
somewhere here
yeah I'm a capital of porns up but
obviously the position is complicated
very hard to to tell what's going on him
I am running right into 96 our grade but
he's not playing that move okay
talk about a tricky position I don't
know c5 this will any good just keeping
d5 protected am I know but now I have
this III counterplay k takes with the
rook okay
I forgot about 96 yeah I can go back
with 96
now that's it's really really going
downhill here very bad play I don't
really have any moves often 96
yeah / ovum he's just pushing pushing
this thing home hi morning really
everything lost him I think I be should
be funny yeah ed ed no moves really no
moves yeah interesting play I mean I
don't really believe it is good against
like perfect defense what he did but it
was very difficult to play let that much
is clear and so this kind of thing yeah
it expected the computer says black is
better but it's very difficult to play
ok I went back went here and it's it's
it's just tough just tough Queen back
when I 96 was possible already but he
didn't do that for some reason and this
one this one oops is 7am and white yeah
the computer is shifting towards wide
it's it's very difficult to play this
thing a5 is what the computer is saying
or whoopsie six yeah it's two pawns but
this this this this night in the middle
of the position is this tricky I have no
big alternatives aware that was very
interestingly played
I don't know maybe he is really better
him the comp is not seeing it but I
don't know oops if I hear maybe from a
practical point of view this was a very
interesting way to play for what how to
hard to defend this very hard to defend
and there are some things that really
cannot I mean if they go wrong for black
they go terribly wrong so if I would
ever need to give up the blockade on his
head which happened in the game I'm just
lost so difficult yeah okay it was an
interesting game nevertheless I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching